we're finally in the endgame now
following the world premiere of Avengers
endgame on Monday April 22nd in downtown
Los Angeles
Marvel Studios lifted the social media
embargo on first reactions to the
superhero epic spoiler free of course
those fortunate enough to attend the
screening ahead of the film's theatrical
debut later this week raised to Twitter
to pour out praise by the bucketful with
critics journalists and members of the
media lionizing is a perfect combination
of the last eleven years of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
one common thread this movie is gonna
make you cry like crazy this is a hot
hot movie I didn't see the ending
because I was crying too much I gave the
three hardware kisses Mashable Zanjeer
Jhon who admitted she wasn't much of a
fan of infinity war wrote that end game
is quote an immensely satisfying payoff
not just to infinity war but to all the
films that came before it Brandon Davis
of comic-book comm had powerful words to
offer regarding Avengers and game he
tweeted hashtag avengers endgame is an
astonishing amazing film I've never seen
anything like it
this movie is everything I wanted it to
be and so much more amazing more
watching hashtag avengers end game I
laughed so loud I clapped with so much
force and I cried so hard the movie
exceeds every expectation and is the
perfect combination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe fandango managing
editor erik davis also noted that
endgame is a flawless intelligence
coming together of the 21 films are
preceded a further teasing that the
flicks ending is a rousing one hashtag
avengers endgame is a masterful epic a
true combination of 22 films that are
only concludes a story but expands upon
it you'll learn more about the other
movies while this one in folds if
infinity war is the brawn end game is
the brains and wow what an ending he
added in follow-up tweets that endgame
stands as its own entity that
complements infinity war even though the
two films were shot back to back and do
deal with the same major threat in the
intergalactic tyrant Thanos meanwhile
audiences should be ready to check their
pride at the door and prepared to bore
their eyes out and laugh hysterically
while watching endgame unfold do not go
in expecting infinity War part 2 the two
films are so different yet complement
each other in all the best ways in terms
of which MCU movie to watch beforehand
honestly all of them one experience one
accomplishment not going to spoil
anything at all but I will say I laughed
I cried I cried I cheered I laughed I
cried again and then the entire audience
gave her a massive standing ovation and
then I cried again be ready kids be
ready
PETA sriracha of / film tweeted that
Avengers end game is incredibly
emotional apparently due to both what
happens within the film and what the
movie means to the larger picture of the
MCU imagine the best possible version of
hashtag Avengers endgame and somehow the
film still surpasses all expectations
I cried 5 to 6 times it's the most
emotional most epic MCU film a tribute
to ten years of this universe and holy
the great fanservice in this movie so
good movie trivia Schmoe down creator
Kristian harloff agreed writing man
hashtag Avengers end game kicked my ass
it was an epic conclusion to 11 years of
films
it had laughs incredible action and
absolute emotional rollercoaster it was
a series finale for this cast of
characters I'd been hoping for Congrats
to all for pulling off the feats
Beatrice for joven senior film reporter
at the wrap has something surprising to
say to fans
none of the theories they came up with
had braced them for endgame so I just
saw a hashtag Avengers endgame and you
guys aren't ready for all the theorizing
didn't prepare you for this I cried a
lot I flung my hands in the air and
screamed out loud it's incredible
David Scott for the New York Times was
so emotionally involved in the film that
he wound up questioning his own
parentage it was not prepared for the
range of emotions a hashtag end game put
me through from utter despair to pure
elation I laughed I cried
I wish Tony Stark was my dad let's
quickly check in with Tony star to see
how he feels about that Denis Shang of
Collider video praised Avengers and
gamers quote an achievement in
blockbuster filmmaking and said hashtag
Avengers endgame is filled of so much
comic-book awesomeness that you may not
be ready of course not everyone
completely freaked the hell out on
Twitter
variety's Matt Donnally kept his
reaction to endgame simple but impactful
incredible ingenuity and commitment
Marvel and Disney can and should be
proud of this moment
Aaron Crouch of The Hollywood Reporter
added to the course of people singing
and games praises
that most of our fans have seen of the
film this far through trailers and TV
spots barely scratches the surface of
the full flick 90% of the hashtag
Avengers endgame footage has been
officially released from the first 15
minutes other than the actual surprises
the biggest surprise to me was how funny
it is cinema blends Eric Eisenberg
offered a response to endgame that will
give you chills this can't be
understated
hashtag Avengers endgame has everything
you wanted to be and more
I am absolutely flawed a perfect
reflection on the last 11 years that
pays off everything in the best way
possible without question my new
favorite Marvel Cinematic Universe film
stunned parry nemi Roth of Collider had
a similar reaction though she warns that
endgame does at times feel overwhelming
in all that Nemiroff feels everything
leading up to the film and to the film's
conclusion was worth a hashtag Avengers
endgame is a lot too much at times but
while the payoff is huge left me proud
to have invested over a decade in a
franchise at the levers and inspiring
exploration of what it means to be
family and a hero endgame also known as
one of my favorite shots in the entire
MCU hmm really better than this show
or this shot overall response to
avengers endgame has been overwhelmingly
positive critics have called it
everything from the greatest superhero
movie ever to entertainment from
beginning to end to film of the year as
always though these are just a selection
of reactions to a film that everyone is
bound to have different opinions about
the fantastic feedback should make fans
giddy as they await the premiere of
Avengers endgame on Friday April 26th
when they'll have the chance to offer
their own thoughts on the superhero epic
until then sit tight and avoid spoilers
and when the time comes as one critic
advised plan your bathroom breaks
accordingly and whatever you do don't be
like Iron Man you know the question I
get asked most often is Tony how do you
go to the bathroom shoot just check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]